make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing up
and uh make sure you guys hit the like
button if you enjoy the video and yeah
let's begin
what's going on guys this is rob and um
first things first before we start this
video i have
never gotten into teenage mutant ninja
turtles which is to say
i watched the tv show briefly when i was
a little kid like a couple episodes i
saw the second well i saw all three
movies i think the second one's the best
one
uh and that's about it right i've never
really read ninja turtles comics uh
never really got into any of the
any of the lore so i've done enough
research that hopefully i kind of get
these things right but for those of you
guys who are members of the rob core
uh and our teenage mutant ninja turtle
fans now's your time to shine
right like take to the comments and
educate all of us on teenage mutant
ninja turtles uh especially me
because i love reaching out to you guys
and learning stuff from you guys and
this is one of those chances
where you guys get to teach me things so
the last ronin
was is really kind of released here as
this story where it's basically
i wouldn't say the end of the road for
the ninja turtles but seems to kind of
take place
in some dystopian future by some kind of
dystopian future and initially here we
pick up with one of the ninja turtles or
seemingly one of the ninja turtles but
we're not really given any indicators as
to who this person is
and this comes from a variety of
different sources the first is the fact
that their bandana or ice trap whatever
you want to call it is basically black
right so it's not designed to cater
towards any one of the ninja turtles
right like it's not
orange it's not purple it's not blue
it's not uh not red
and so we don't really know which guy
this is now we could look at the weapons
to give us an indicator of which ninja
turtle this is but this guy has the
staff
he's got the sword he's got the size and
presumably he's got nunchucks in there
somewhere right so
uh we're not really given an answer on
who this guy is and of course that's
obviously designed to be intentional but
the other part of that
is that they're he's basically making
his way towards
what looks like a completely cordoned
off uh manhattan right a completely
cordoned off manhattan island now the
other part of that is it looks as though
like with this this kind of sludge
basically what passes for water being
toxic that with it being at some point
in the future
things like climate change pollution
stuff like that have all seemed to have
kind of run rampant and almost puts
forward this idea
that the earth or or seemingly this part
of the world maybe new york is in a lot
of ways just kind of a derelict place
now a lot of those pollution stuff seems
to be coming from this city so maybe it
may not just be the world
but it looks like it's one of these
things where in a typical
post-apocalyptic landscape
you have what you normally see which is
to say the more or less collapse of
modern society and what came out of it
was essentially the rise of strongmen
and petty warlords regardless of the
situation
you know this guy starts making his way
through you know all this all this water
you know basically takes out a couple of
ninja stars and takes out cameras right
so this mission
is basically one of infiltration and
it's looking to kind of
get revenge on a particular person right
and that's what's kind of
wild about this because the statement
here or at least we're getting
statements like it's time to finish this
or die trying and so there seems to be
some history here right there seems to
be some history in so far as if this is
the only ninja turtle that we see
and the story is called the last ronin
basically this person or you know this
this
this experience happened in such a way
to where all the other ninja turtles are
killed
but it is a little strange because what
we seem to kind of get here are these
conversations right you have like three
ninja turtles in the background and are
basically talking to this guy and this
guy in turn is talking back to them so
it's a little bit mysterious here now
the fact that they're their dress and
your typical ninja turtle garb
the fact that we're just now being
introduced to them seems to lend itself
or seems to lend credence to the idea
that he's only seeing
seeing them and they're only seeing him
but again the mystery and build up here
is actually pretty amazing right it's
it's pretty awesome
but once it gets into the city we get a
little more of an indication
of what this guy's capable of or at
least how in particular it is that this
guy sees the world right because as soon
as he gets there
we're kind of giving this indication
that you know manhattan more or less as
it exists now
exists in two different ways right like
new york exists in two different forms
there's kind of the lower city and the
upper city and you guys will see what
i'm talking about here in a minute but
the the conversation between this guy
and seemingly the other ninja turtles is
this guy express a little bit of
frustration in the sense that once he
gets out there to the street he realizes
this place is wildly overcrowded right
so this is kind of an indication that he
hasn't been here for quite some time now
the other ninja turtles are like what
did you think it was going to be like a
stroll in the park you just kind of
casually make your way up to the tower
and then everything you just kind of
enact your revenge and that's it like
how did you see this playing out in your
head right like you're in the real world
now right like you gotta you gotta be
able to navigate the real world
and that's the kind of thing that we get
here is one of the things he tells
himself is adapt and overcome
right or do not right you know like one
of these two things has to happen it's
not necessarily a thing about luck
there's a thing about being able to
examine your circumstances and overcome
your circumstances accordingly and so
what ends up happening here
is that a handful of what are basically
bikers end up coming out of what looks
like a local bar or a local restaurant
and then
basically the bike of a woman named
jones is missing now if i'm a betting
man
i would say this person is somehow
connected to casey jones i don't know if
that's true or not
i'm just kind of speculating we're not
really given any indication here but if
i remember correctly back in the day
they used to refer to casey jones as
jones right so do not take that as an
absolute
i could be entirely wrong but of course
this ninja turtle basically ends up
racing off on the motorcycle but when
they get to what looks like this kind of
tower of sorts right this this head
building
that they end up finding a bit of a road
a bit of a roadblock in the sense that
uh there's no easy accessible way in
where they won't be detected and so what
they actually end up doing is creating a
diversion
in one of the coolest ways possible
right like they even say it's as far as
like snake plushkin style
right so like those of you guys who
don't know who snake pluskin is he's
from escape from new york and escaped
from
los angeles it was uh oh my god what was
his name kurt russell that's what i'm
thinking of it was kurt russell
uh but nonetheless this like what this
guy ends up doing is basically getting
on the motorcycle right riding back a
little ways getting on the motorcycle
and jumping it over the fence and into a
tanker truck
right blows the whole thing up and gets
himself to the wall
and then basically enters through what
looks like a like a drainage hole
and so once he starts kind of climbing
through there going through all this
this cabling and all that kind of stuff
that he basically ends up making his way
through it but notice this like a kind
of conversation between himself
and the other ninja turtles it's kind of
cool right they're like well that was
graceful
right you literally blew up a tanker in
order to get yourself here so you get
yourself into this into this building
and now you're gonna climb through
what's basically a manhole he's like it
worked didn't it like that's the only
thing that really matters it's like it
works
and he's like and then the other thing
he offers here is like don't let your
eyes deceive you right like this nose
never forgets the smell even if it looks
different this is still
our turf right nothing's changed what
matters is like
this is our this this is still our home
turf and so as he gets in there once he
crawls through the hole he ends up quite
literally in the middle of everything so
this is kind of like the worst the worst
situation to happen i guess
outside of like you know basically
crawling out and into like the middle of
the police department in the barracks
right like that seems to be
probably maybe maybe worse than this but
in this instance he crawls out of the
hole he's just surrounded by everybody
and as soon as that happens we get a
couple indications right immediately
the the armored guards right what
basically passes for street cops
in this particular landscape immediately
started activating under like intruder
grabbing and the other thing that we're
shown here is by way of the people
dressing
right looking a lot more casual you know
kind of dressing a little more high end
this kind of looks to be the upper city
and we get that from a couple places in
the sense you've got this kind of dome
this stretches over the top
you've got taller buildings so it's not
like it's just a store this is an actual
street you know with people on it and
things along those lines and so as soon
as that happens
this guy is on the run and that's the
way it's going to be like for the most
part the rest of this right he's going
to continually be on the run he throws
down smoke bombs
that offer a distraction and then
basically takes off and is that
happening
he ends up getting you know at least
these these guys end up reporting you
know hey like there's an intruder he's
heading down this location and and so on
and as he takes out this cop uh
basically beats the crap out of him with
a night stick as he takes this cop out
uh this this guy just kind of keeps
reiterating the same thing right just
saying hulk but when he's defeated and
part of his mask is broken he looks
human underneath
and the conversation between this guy
and the other ninja turtles is okay
uh is this guy human or is he synthetic
and the logical assumption is that he's
synthetic
right that this guy has knowledge of
technology right knowledge of of
advanced technology you know and this
guy looks at that and says it looks like
he's synthetic
right that's that's what it looks like
like this guy looks like he's just a
normal person or at least one of the
other ninja turtles seems to say that
right this guy's like a normal guy right
so it's kind of like okay
it's interesting i mean because largely
at this point we can assume like that's
donatello that's that's
michelangelo or it's leonardo or it's
raphael we don't really know who the
other three
are because we don't know who this guy
is right we just know he's one of the
ninja turtles and so because of that
you kind of get this sort of ping where
a couple other officers show up realize
this guy's been
been disabled but what it means is he
has to basically speed up his timeline
because now that the enemy force is
aware that he's there and these guys
kind of look like i mean they got swords
they look like foot right they look like
the foot soldiers
now that we now they know this guy's
here then one he has to incapacitate
them as best he can
but two because they're being
incapacitated they're not reporting back
and because they're not reporting back
that means something's going on right i
mean we already know there's an intruder
there so now like the intruder is not
being caught
and that's gonna lead to heightened
levels of security and so this guy
literally jumps from like apartment
building to apartment building
going from place to place just literally
quite you know fleeing for his life and
trying to achieve his goal
and constantly being caught up with
these guys but notice this for the most
part he's able to overcome them
quite readily like they're not a huge
threat to this guy
one of the other cool things that you
get here is of course this is kind of a
place where you have hover cars and
different things like that right so
technology is full-on advanced here
he actually like jumps off a bridge
lands on a car like lands in a police
car
throws the cop out and then commandeers
the car and then the car crashes through
through like a sign
so then he jumps out of the car lands on
the ground
and takes off running for him like takes
off running for his life right just kind
of going and going and going now what we
end up finding out here
is this person is looking to track down
oroku hiroto
now from here we switch over to hiroto
himself and we only get this brief
little moment here right in the sense
that he's talking to you know one of his
guys talking to his captain and he says
yeah we've got kind of a situation down
there and hirono's initial response is
or at least you know has he's informed
by his captain
it's an intruder and it may be like a
rogue derelict from the bottom district
right so somebody from the very very
bottom who is basically operating in the
middle district or causing problems
and this really kind of shows a couple
things the first thing it shows us is
that that
the the kind of cast society which is to
say like hierarchies
right so the the class society rather is
still intact right the lower class the
middle class and the upper class the
other thing it shows
is that this guy really kind of
underestimates the various forces that
are out there right that you have people
who are in the lower class who seem to
rebel
on not really a regular frequency but
every once in a while
by trying to like destroy things in the
middle class or the upper class or
something along those lines now
they seem to be put down with quite
harshly and that really seems to be the
case because one herodo is not too
concerned right so it's one of these
things where his attitude indicates that
previous
instances previous attempts to rebel
have been quashed quite readily uh
readily so he's pretty
confident in his ability to quash this
one as well and he actually authorizes
uh
lethal force right so this guy had this
this this guy here
has no problem using lethal force
against basically lowercas
lower class citizens to keep people in
their place right to make an example of
what happens when you try to step
outside of your class now
at that point we switch back over to
this ninja turtle and we get a little
bit of history here right we end up
finding out
that this guy is the so-called master of
the foot clan
as it exists today that he's basically
uh karai's bastard son
and and the shredder's grandson now who
kara is i have no idea right ninja
turtle fans this is your time
teach me something right teach me
something down in the comments section
like it gets a typing right teach me all
that stuff
um i mean i guess i could look it up but
in all honesty sometimes i just don't
like looking things up and i like asking
you guys right that's one of the things
that i've learned from the discord
server
is that a lot of you guys really just
like teaching me stuff
right like and i think that's kind of
cool right to kind of sidetrack here for
a second i'm gonna be honest i don't
really see that as a lazy thing
i see that as a cool thing because one
of the things that you guys have always
seemed to express
interest in is as much as i've taught
you guys about comics
like about like marvel and dc comics
like you guys have wanted to teach me
things about like other comic books
right like there's been times when i've
gone into
uh discord and be like hey guys can you
guys teach me about my transformers and
where to start you guys come out of the
woodwork right like you guys come out of
nowhere and just and literally just like
yeah man dude let me teach you
everything i know about like about
transformers right like you guys seem to
love
that kind of banter so i like leaning
into that but i like playing into that
and and giving you guys a chance to to
basically be heard
and to like teach me stuff right you
guys really seem to enjoy that so
nonetheless you know this guy as he
makes his way into what is really kind
of like this upper class and and
seemingly what looks like
this sort of point where he can actually
enter the tower proper uh
you know security is exactly what you
would expect it to be it's far more
heightened right you're talking about
what looks like their police force right
so you're talking about like arms and
armament that are
pretty significant but this guy also
draws a pretty logical conclusion and
says okay like i need to get a ride into
this place because what they won't be at
won't be expecting is a direct attack
they won't be expecting somebody to
directly infiltrate their tower
that you know that kind of combined with
the fact that this is like
military-grade uh military-grade
equipment things like that
combined with our understanding of uh of
herodo
basically seems to indicate that like no
one's ever really made it this far
right so it's one thing they wouldn't
expect that if there's some kind of an
intruder out there they would be put
down
hard and fast which is kind of a great
way or at least seemingly
a poignant way to show anybody else out
there if you try to rebel
will take care of you with a quickness
but what what you're dealing with here
is a ninja turtle right this is not some
average joe who's just really fed up
with their lot in life picks up a
handgun and decides to take it to the
man right like this is a guy
who's trained in espionage trained in
ninjutsu trained to infiltrate to strike
hard
and get out fast right that's what this
guy's trained to do and so with that
being the case like literally
every weapon that he has at his disposal
comes into play like he just
busts into this place right like head-on
straight attack
and immediately goes to work on these
guys and notice this this guy's like a
one-man
wrecking crew and it's kind of nuts to
be honest right like this guy's weapons
are coming out of the woodwork right so
like his ninja size he's throwing smoke
bomb or throwing little explosives
like literally taking these guys out
super fast the other part of this though
is that
unlike the guys he fought on the street
these are more elite right they're more
militarized and so because of that these
guys
strike just as hard right they are
exceedingly fast and wildly capable the
funny thing about this though is that
this ninja turtle kind of looks at that
and says
like like machines do all the fighting
for this guy like that's kind
of pathetic right and it's very very
gutless like what kind of a person what
kind of a leader who calls himself a
master has no honor and has
other people do his bidding for him
right like you know what's what's the
idea behind that like
you can't simply come down here now the
other part of this comes from us
sort of transitioning back and forth
between heroda and uh and this guy and
so you know and so far as hiroto kind of
looks at this and says like why is this
guy in my lower levels right like you
know you don't understand
uh that i'm gonna have his head on a
pike before this day is over
and keeps sending all his various forces
in now the funny thing about this is
that once this guy appears on a camera
then hiroto realizes this guy's a ninja
turtle right so
they're not supposed to exist seemingly
right they're supposed to be gone
and so with that being the case this
guy's like get every single member of
the foot
and bring them in right so as most of
you guys have figured out by now
this is all foot stuff right this city
is ran by a guy who's the master of the
foot
and the foot are no longer just like
ninjas who exist out there i mean they
are to a degree but there seems to be a
kind of blend that took place turning
them all basically into cyborgs with
varying levels of technology right like
you know
like like street level foot are
basically cops the more advanced ones
are military that kind of a thing
and we'll see even more advanced ones
than these guys but it's kind of nuts
here because
you end up seeing of course this guy
taking each one of these guys out right
taking each one of these guys on and
then he ends up coming across what are
basically the
elite ninja foot clan right these are
these elite soldiers who he takes out
with a quickness as well right i mean
there's not really much in the way of of
a battle going on here i mean
in the span of of like six panels like
not even six pages
six panels right it's like foot and then
neck
and then like overcome this guy and then
stab him through the chest and then cut
a guy's arm off and then cut it like
literally just
chopping these guys down piece by piece
taking these guys down
bit by bit and then it turns into
activate the stockman tech now
i have no idea what the stockmantech is
but i don't know what that reference is
i i see like okay here's one thing to
understand about comics guys
in comic books whenever you see a word
or a name that's in bold
it's a reference to something and i feel
like those of you guys out there who
know what this is are just like
yes like this is amazing you guys like
this is amazing this is awesome
like it's it's it's kind of cool like if
i'm being honest i'm super excited to
read your comments
[Laughter]
but the other thing about that is that
this guy keeps calling out herodo right
he keeps calling him out like come and
face me right like
like your destiny is at hand come and
face me here the problem with this
is that this guy keeps sending his own
robots right and so what he ends up
doing is is by sending out the stockman
tech oh wait a minute stockman was the
fly guy wasn't he he was the fly dude
from from the cartoon shows back in the
day yeah john saw he was
not john stockman uh stockman was he was
the guy who was like part fly or
something like that i don't remember i
remember there was a ninja turtles movie
back in the day
and maybe it's i don't remember how it
explained how we got bebop and
rocksteady which i'm kind of sad to see
they're not here to be honest
i missed bebop and rocksteady hey boss
this this food sucks boss you're a
terrible boss shredder you get beat all
the time but nonetheless
i kind of miss bebop and rocksteady
right they were they were kind of funny
but unless like this this
guy he ends up throwing out like an emp
takes care of the small ones with the
big ones he kind of goes in for a direct
attack
and that's where he gets tripped up
because what ends up happening is this
guy just is
running at him full speed dives at him
and he can't slow their momentum
right and so literally they both go
crashing through a window and this guy
goes falling right falling falling
falling falling and then smashes into
the ground now he does survive it
but just barely this guy's bleeding out
of the mouth he's like herodo like
you're a coward having your guys do your
business for you like this is this is
ridiculous
and starts calling him out right saying
like this is not done yet you know like
everything in my body feels broken
somehow i'm still alive and then
suddenly these guys start showing up
these police you know more or less start
showing up and saying like everybody
disperse right everybody get out of here
but people aren't dispersing
people are curious right and in their
curiosity they stick around and kind of
watch what happens
and that's when they're like lethal
force authorized and they're like we're
gonna start killing you if you don't
leave and so
basically this girl joan says hey uh the
guy you're looking for went that way and
sends these guys in the wrong direction
and then she basically ends up following
this kind of trail of blood into a sewer
main right now once she gets down to the
sewer main
uh you kind of have this this
interesting situation where you have her
following
uh this ninja turtle right through all
this you know eventually locating him
and then realizing it's a ninja turtle
right like realizing oh my god now
before she finds him
what what you get is this guy basically
kind of taking his
taking his garb off right and and
literally like pulling his weapons out
and then seemingly coming to terms with
where he's at right the other ninja
turtles are talking to him and saying
dude like you don't have to do this
and he's like stop no more talking like
if i'm gonna end this i'm gonna end it
on my terms right for my family for my
honor
he seems to more or less accept that
he's been soundly defeated and so what
he ends up doing and this is what's
crazy about this and you know what he
ends up doing
is taking all the eye all the eye bands
of the ninja turtles and laying them
down right so like leonardo raphael
donate
donatello and michelangelo and so the
initial thought was okay this guy is a
wholly different ninja turtle right like
this guy isn't even one of the original
ninja turtles he's a wholly different
guy which seems kind of crazy you know
and then he says like i miss my brother
so much and this is cool because if this
if this gives us the idea that it is a
wholly different ninja turtle it's not
related to any of the other four
then my question immediately becomes
where did he come from why have we never
heard of him
and what is this dude's origin story
right like that's kind of nuts then he
goes as far as to say i miss my father
right so i miss splinter and so he lays
down all their personal belongings
and seemingly in a kind of tribute
offers some some measure of a prayer to
them
and then he in turn intends to commit
sepaku right to basically commit suicide
and so where he initially goes to try to
stab himself he says
no like i can't do that i can't do it
not yet not like this my mission's not
complete and so he basically ends up
passing out
and that's when this girl realizes oh my
god it's a ninja turtle right so from
that point this guy's vital signs seem
to go flat right so he seems to just
kind of die
more or less that kind of seems to be
the case or the very least kind of pass
out right his vitals are just super weak
and then he wakes up in this bed
and he's surrounded by all the other
ninja turtles right he's surrounded by
like everybody else and it's kind of
nuts because we're still not told who
this guy
is instead he's kind of like like where
where are we at like you know
when the guys wake him up they're like
you know we got things to do he's like
where like like where are we at man like
like somebody crashed a cement truck
into my skull right and it's the kind of
banter
that we're used to with the ninja
turtles right this kind of brotherly
conversation between these four guys and
so again this guy looks like he
is one of the original original ninja
turtles right so it kind of destroys
that theory right off the bat that he's
kind of a missing one that we didn't
really know anything about or something
along those lines you know and he's like
he's like is this the old sewer they're
like yeah man i mean what did you think
you were in the ritz like we're ninja
turtles man we operate in the sewer like
we've always been broke we've never had
money man like
i mean come on man like we've always
been the guys who ate ramen noodles and
pizza like
he's like that's that's kind of what it
is right and so finally he wakes up
right like somebody says like thank god
you're up and this guy snaps up only to
be met by the arrival of april o'neil
and it's like
holy cow like april o'neil's here right
and he's like is it really you she's
like yeah it's me you know and i'm
relieved to see that you're awake
but like who were you talking to and she
calls him michelangelo
and so it's official the last surviving
ninja turtle
is none other than michelangelo with
that being said guys we're gonna bring
this video to an end
if you are new here to comments explain
make sure you guys hit the sub button to
become part of the rob core if you guys
enjoyed this video
make sure you drop a like and i will
catch you all later
peace
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you